- Hey legal eagles.
Law school is really expensive,
so students are always
asking me if they should work
during law school to help defray the cost.
Well today we're gonna talk
about the pros and cons
of working during law school
and whether it's right for you.
By the end of this video you'll know
whether you should take a job while being
a full time law student, so stick around.
(soft rhythmic instrumental music)
Law school is an investment,
it has a high upfront cost,
tuition is often over
50,000 dollars per year,
plus living expenses which add in another
20 to 30,000 dollars.
It's not uncommon for students to graduate
with over 200,000 dollars
in law school debt alone,
so I understand the inclination
to work during law school
to help defray some of those costs.
The question is should you
work during law school?
Is it worth it?
In my opinion, if you are
a full time law student,
no, you should not work during law school,
absolutely not, don't even think about it,
and there's several reasons for this.
First, law school is like
having two full time jobs
already, you go to class from 10 to three,
and then study from three to nine,
and you work weekends as well.
Law school alone just doing the studying
and preparing for class and going to class
is basically like two full
time jobs back to back.
It doesn't seem like
there's additional time
to factor in another full time job.
On top of that law school
entails a different kind
of studying than most people are used to
and it will take you
longer to prepare for class
than you're accustomed to.
You will read so much more
than you did in college
and unlike college you can't fake reading
the assigned reading like you did before
in your classes in undergrad.
Almost all first year law students
face a very steep learning curve.
You're going to have a vocabulary of words
that you've never heard
before or regular words
that have a different
meaning in the legal context,
it's a whole new set of rules.
It's like learning
piano, guitar, and chess
all at the same time concurrently
in different classes.
And that's why the ABA
actually puts a limit
on how much you can work in law school.
The ABA says that you can
work no more than 20 hours
per week for full time law students.
So they're cognizant of
the fact that you should be
focusing on law school and not other,
other monetary opportunities.
Another factor is stress,
law school is already
considered the most stressful
time in students' lives.
I've seen Marines have mental breakdowns
under the stress of law
school, so adding another job
on top of that is just
a recipe for disaster.
But most importantly, the
thing about law school
is that grades matter.
The most important thing that you can do
to get the job that you
want in the legal field
is to get good grades.
Grades are 90% of what
it takes to get the job
that you want, whether it's a big firm job
or a clerkship or going
into public interest,
everyone is going to look at your grades
and better grades will
open up more opportunities.
And if you take on a job
you will be competing
against students who are not working
and who are focusing on law school 100%,
and that's an unfair competition.
One of the main points of law
school is to become a lawyer,
yes, but it's also to
increase your earning power
by getting into the state run monopoly,
that is the Attorney's Bar.
So part of the point of becoming a lawyer
is to earn more as an attorney.
So let's say that you
were somehow able to make
50,000 dollars per year
while in law school.
I don't think that's very realistic
while actually being in law school,
but let's say you were able
to make 50,000 dollars,
but at the cost of slipping
a few points in your GPA.
Well the difference between graduating
in the top 10% of your class
and the middle 50% or so
could result in a difference
in salary when you graduate
of 50,000 dollars less in year one.
And that difference or deficit
is only going to compound
year after year after year.
The place where you
start when you graduate
largely determines where
you end up five, 10,
and 20 years later.
So while it might've made
sense to earn 50,000 dollars
while in law school, that
could end up costing you
millions of dollars over
the course of your career.
And keep in mind that
your 1L year is by far
the most important year in law school.
Your 1L grades will
define where you're able
to get a 1L summer job
and those two things
will define where you're able
to get a 2L summer associate job,
and that's largely where people get their
employment prospects when
they graduate from law school.
So if ever there was a year
not to have another job
it would be your 1L year.
When you get into your 2L and 3L year
you'll probably get
your feet underneath you
and you can decide
whether you wanna take on
the additional risk of another job
or perhaps some
extracurricular activities.
But your first year grades will define
whether you're able to get a clerkship
or a summer internship or
whether you're possibly
able to transfer to a better school.
So don't short change your 1L
grades above everything else.
And in fact, many schools prevent you
from doing extracurriculars
during your first year,
let alone a full time job.
So the bottom line is
that getting another job,
especially during your 1L year,
but probably for the rest of law school,
it's just not worth it.
Don't go down that road,
don't be penny wise
and pound foolish, understand law school
for the investment that it is.
You're probably going to
be taking on a large amount
of loans and it would be
terrible to throw away
that investment just to
get a few more dollars
during the school year
which will really impact
your ability to get good grades.
So in my view having a
full time job in law school
just isn't worth it.
Focus on your grades,
focus on your final exams,
and do the best that you can.
That will have the best
result in succeeding
in law school and your
career as an attorney.
Now if you're preparing for law school
and want even more strategies and tactics
that will show you how
to get A's in law school
download our free Ultimate
Pre-law Checklist,
it's our free gift to you, the
link to that is down below.
It will give you a head
start on your peers
by the time you get to law school.
And also please click on the
like and subscribe buttons,
the more people that
subscribe the more videos
we'll make on how to crush law school.
So did you work during law school?
Did you regret it or did you
think it was a great idea?
Let me know in the comments,
I'd love to hear from you,
and until next time at Legal Eagle,
think like a lawyer and ace the exam.
Hey legal eagles, bah
blah blah, blah blah blah.
Okay.
You will read so much more
than you did in college.
Did I say that right?
So let's say that you
are somehow able to make
50,000 dollars per year in law school.